Almost everyone knows about Google.
Google is an incredible search tool on the Internet.
Google can help you find almost everything on the Internet.
It's like magic.
Type any word or sentence into the search box and see what you find.
What do you like to google?
I love soccer!
Soccer is the most popular sport in the world.
Google can help you find all kinds of information about soccer around the world.
Google can find soccer websites, soccer photos and soccer videos.
Did you know that you can even look down at soccer stadiums with the Google Earth tool?
Wow, Google is pretty amazing.
Here are some fun facts about Google:
Google was invented by two college students in the 1990s.
Google now has some 20,000 employees.
Google is worth billions of dollars.